ces dessins du bar celle qui habite
l'appartement ses 125 ans et qui vient
de commander un thé citron avec un jus
d'orange des hausses beurre confiture et
les journaux du matin mais ont rejeté
par marino tholot tu perds et médéa plus
lentement
marie lou tau lot marie lou tau
on se provoque marilou tholot marie
marie laforêt marilou tholot la star
italienne
mon dieu qu'est les yeux verts comme ça
ne marche pas comme ça les gars la
tournée avec richard burton
la tournée va tourner dans dans
barbe-bleue avec lui avec lino ventura
la tournée la peau des autres attendent
avec gaubert à la tournée avec cailloux
et là il vient de finir j'ai noté rien
au delà de la peur avec constantin et
michel bouchez fait ça avant mais toi là
tu l'as dit c'est pour quoi faire et
qu'il a dû monter moi non je perds du
sat avance un coup dur les cas triple a
le coeur sur la main
on croit rêver je reçois une commande du
627 et uniquement histoire de mettre un
peu de rose soit grisaille de ta matinée
laborieuse se dit qu' elle vient et
voilà comment tu me remercient tu
m'insultes parce que je fais mon travail
par une loi que je te remplace un pour
le 625 qui pourra toujours courir oui
hélas comptait sur lui et a toujours sa
fermeture éclair qui est un peu coincé
forêt de qui t'appelle
des l'avenir ats la partie au mieux au
team dégoûte
tu n'es qu'un gigolo violent tout cas
j'ai ma conscience pour nom sacha écoute
soit chouette
moi je moi j'aime cette femme j'aime
cette femme c'est la chance de ma vie
sachant qu'elle rentre sentez que vous
écoutez moi aussi j'ai envie de la voir
marie le tall en fait c'est quand même
incroyable fébrilité des vous des fois
il est fou il est chic
serez-vous litres malades
après le petit déjeuner de mademoiselle
tholot après c'est vrai que je ne
voudrais pas que ça refroidisse
mais vous ne pouvez pas des salles et
dans son bas j'ai la préviendrait dans
un instant madame ne désire rien pour
elle même ça va très bien vous pouvez
disposer merci
excusez-moi j'ai frappé à la porte de la
chambre
on va apparaître que je suis entré avec
le plateau j'ai attendu les personnes je
me suis dit que ça va refroidir
alors j'ai pensé que vers frapper à la
porte de la salle de bains et vous avez
bien fait parce que vous avez avec l'eau
qui coule on attend p1 prenantes en rien
je le pose ici je vais vous servir
voulez mais très fort ac oui même si
assez fort qu'est ce que tu fais là vous
qu'est ce que vous faites là je suis
venu voir si vous ne venez pas delà de
la pure delà de la purée de pommes de
pommes de terre plus facilement
je prends pas les petits déjeuners avec
la purée de pommes de terre
mais non il appuie un peu attardé en
direct le garde ici par gentillesse mais
on fait pas attendre sinon il faut pas
faire tout c'est triste mais les gros
ravages et si oui les parents boivent
c'est les enfants qui trinquent
vous pouvez par contre je suis venu tout
à leur portée votre plateau de petits
dégénéré là une dame blonde avec une
robe de chambre bleue qui m'a dit
qu'elle ne vous préviendrai que
s'étaient servis alors je suis reparti
et puis voilà je viens voir s'il
manquait rien pardon j'ai pas que vous
vous êtes trompé de chambre basse qui
s'il n'y a pas une dame blonde avec une
robe de chambre
oui toi elle a laissé sa sa perruque
blonde et sa robe de chambre bleue la
confession d'un bel ami que tu veux dire
non pas des sandales que ça c'est rien
ça s'est resserré
mais non c'est quoi alors oui vous
pouvez les passer bah écoutez moi je
suis ravi de vivre en france mais j'ai
tout vu que les gens ils sont un peu
changé mais je vais vous expliquer les
homes et cela pas la porte
on se voit tout à l'air de bois oui un
très vif
nous avons débarrassé de ses deux
imbéciles et médéric quelque chose
d'autre pour vous ben oui je vous en
prie on peut prendre le petit déjeuner à
la française venait france à change
constant oui quel sur 10 vous voulez du
thé oui oui je veux oui avec un petit
trou au dessus mais c'est merveilleux
quand je veux raconter sa discipline
bieber est la mienne mais risque et
connaît bien
c'est dans la malade malade c'est là
qu'on a